the media was initially critical of
president biden's handling of
afghanistan but now some are providing
cover for the commander-in-chief
especially when it comes to his call
with the former afghan president msnbc's
chris hayes tweeting telling the failing
afghan government to fake it till you
make it as a means of extending its
reign as long as possible is a sad
statement on cumulative u.s failures in
afghanistan but not a scandal any more
than the war itself was and take a look
at this commentary over president biden
facing intense criticism for leaving
americans behind in afghanistan
i think people should stop beating up on
the administration
so much
because no matter how it ended everyone
wasn't going to be happy with the way it
ended you can't get them all out
in five minutes you can't get them all
out yesterday so what happens going
forward if we continue with this effort
to get them out and we start getting
them out as many out as possible then i
think that we should stop all you know
running around like oh my gosh i can't
believe we left somebody
let's start with you uh again don lemon
goes there too you can't get everybody
out five minutes it's sort of this straw
man thing again like well we couldn't
stay there forever nobody's saying you
stay there forever and nobody's saying
everybody gets out in five minutes wait
he said we don't know if people were
left behind actually we do because i'm
fighting
joe biden said admit it
that we left people behind centcom
commander general frank mckenzie the day
prior on monday said uh we left people
behind
i didn't think it was possible for him
to have less credibility
but i guess if you're a repellent gas
bag you want to be the most repellent
gaseous gas bag that you can possibly be
it's the same person who greg has talked
about over and over dismissed and
scoffed at violence and mayhem in the
street and said well i went out to eat
dinner
and you know we didn't see anything we
just saw
uh i digress but i
they're trying to prop up somebody who
has had the worst record of any
politician on foreign policy ever this
commander-in-chief again wasn't for the
raid on to get osama bin laden so what's
the motive other than just to hear
themselves talk i mean there's there's a
lot to dissect and what has happened
over the last couple of weeks and i'm
hoping i think we all do that we'll have
transparency we'll get some answers
about this but jessica i'm old enough to
remember when there was talk of the 25th
amendment over president trump because
the way he held a glass or walk down a
ramp so it seems like there is a
different standard for where the media
is handling some of these presidential
decisions
yeah they don't like president trump and
they like president i mean it's pretty
simple like i like my friends i don't
like people are not my friends yeah
i have been consistent which i'm
thrilled about that i don't like talking
about anyone's cognitive state it is
reckless none of us are anyone's doctors
physical mental
any of it and i think all of that should
have been
left out of the conversation so the
point about the coverage it's
interesting because there is something
going on on far left media so i know to
a lot of conservatives they just think
like anything left is far left but it's
not true right so there's like
progressive then there's establishment
and then there's you know people
drifting towards the right and the far
left has been screaming at the medium
left from the beginning that they are
being too harsh
about on president biden like how you
know he's making good on all these
promises this is all trump's deals
trump's the one that released 5 000
taliban fighters etc and when you look
at the fact that the investigation into
the withdrawal is being led by bob
menendez who is a huge ally of president
biden's when you look at how much air
time someone like congressman seth
moulton
is getting right he's leading msnbc
shows to talk about why he and
congressman peter meyer who's a
republican went over there and came back
and said it is a complete debacle that
every there are so many different
realities to this coverage going on
depending on what denomination of
political affiliation you are so but but
will this that may be then what people
thought the media was 20 years ago that
there were divergent viewpoints and they
were covering everything and trying to
be fair and asking questions of the left
and the right so
not to be argumentative out of genuine
curiosity who would you define as the
medium left media because i find it very
hard to distinguish in 2021 it feels to
me like they're all radical far left so
i'm be curious who's medium well you
don't have the special glasses i have
that's where you can't figure out what
it is
no it's obviously i mean within networks
is there are anywhere there are certain
hosts that you know are more extreme
that aren't like if you watched jake
tapper's coverage for instance on cnn
for the first couple weeks of this he
had more veterans on criticizing what
was going on in afghanistan than i would
say some conservative leaning media did
i would suggest we should ask all the
medium-left media members whether or not
men can get pregnant and we can find out
if anyone truly has any rationality left
within the medium left or the same as
the radical left i'll tell you what they
are though they're consistent so degen
we can give cnn some credit so their
media coverage is a little bit like
their foreign policy advocacy
close enough that was close to truth you
know what we kind of got them all out
like a game of horseshoes you know we're
kind of close to the pin and we might
have left a couple thousand close enough
that's what lemon seems to be advocating
for close enough is good enough just
like his adherence to the truth i think
really quickly sharing the more
offensive tweet you could have showed
from chris hayes is the one where on the
day 13 servicemen died he said well for
context 13 americans died from covet
today he compared an act of terrorism
and violence to a pandemic and the
reason he did that is because while
there's a clear bad guy when it comes to
terrorism the left increasingly wants to
paint their fellow american as our true
enemy as the bad guy and the true
american there would be
masking or vaccination the bad guys in
their mind are their fellow americans
and that's why on that day he wanted to
point it to covid
greg i feel like you have something to
say all right itching over here no no
i'm not i'm just i i like your color
against the blue it's fine do you want
to see it again yeah it was very look at
that it pops i love how don lemon says
lay off joe because we don't know
we don't know if he left any if we left
anybody behind since when did ignorance
of facts keep cnn from saying anything
if that were the new criteria the cnn
would just be one long test pattern
punctuated by the voice of james earl
jones going this is cnn because they
would be that's all they do they've
never cared whether they knew something
or not country you know our problem is
other countries have propaganda but it's
directed outward to their adversaries or
their right their other countries their
rivals our propaganda in our country is
directed inward you have people that
claim to be news anchors but they're
actually commentators we don't claim to
be news anchors except for shannon
because she is i'm not
we aren't we're just we just it's news
to me yes it is but they over at cnn
they pretend to be commentators and
they're propagandizing for joe biden so
while you know so all of a sudden what
you're going to see is you're going to
see them pivot which they did on msnbc
this morning i think they led with uh
january 6th the phone call that jim
jordan made to trump that was what we're
back to phone yeah we're back that phone
call so what you're seeing is you're
going to see the pivot and they're going
to try they're going to treat january 6
like a cpr dummy and just keep trying to
revive it all the way through next year
because that's the only thing they have
and
meanwhile they they see this is no big
deal
that's propaganda and we direct it at
ourselves hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else